in giuliana trattoria ist man gut und
günstig das sagen alle in bergamo kein
wunder dass man kaum einen platz kriegt
hier machen wir fleischbällchen die
chefin kontrolliert in der küche
höchstpersönlich ob alles läuft ob die
berühmte polenta genug gerührt ist wegen
der kommen viele fußballfans des
heimatvereins atalanta bergamo nach den
spielen hier her und weil juliana eine
von ihnen ist ein atalanta fan durch und
durch schon ein leben lang
klar die spieler und der trainer sogar
der präsident von atalanta kommt hierher
und die fans die ultras ich bin eine
ehemalige ultra jetzt wo ich so alt bin
sitze ich auf der tribüne weil es bequem
ist aber mein blut ist immer noch das
eines ultra fans ich meine es heißt mich
immer noch mit wenn ich atalanta höhere
oder bergamo
immer wenn atalanta bergamo ein
heimspiel harz bereitet sie sich daher
besonders vor kauft sie besonders viel
ein das am abend atalanta spielt weiß
auch die verkäuferin
[Musik]
weiß nicht ich müsste jemand finden der
mich im lokal vertritt aber es ist ja
gut dass die leute wieder ausgehen
zum glück findet auch giuliana und
bestellt für den abend gleich mal
ordentlich fleischspezialitäten
das leben ist wieder fast normal in
bergamo die infektionsrate mit einer
inzidenz von 79 eine der niedrigsten in
ganz italien
die menschen bewegen sich wieder
unbeschwert
[Musik]
die leute sind jetzt mal abgesehen von
den sorgen die bei der aktuellen
gesamtlage hochkommen aber weißt du
während corona war kein mensch unterwegs
ich habe aus meinem fenster geschaut und
es sah aus wie auf dem mond oder so eine
seltsame szene es war richtig schlimm
aber
vielleicht ist das genau das was die
menschen überzeugt hat weil sie nicht
noch einmal so etwas erleben wollten wie
vor zwei jahren die meisten sind geimpft
auch beim fußball läuft dass ihre
fußball helden spielen gerade richtig
gut und die fans können auch bei den
spielen dabei sein mit sicherheit
auflagen und der strengen kontrolle des
super green basels der belegt dass man
geimpft oder genesen ist zweig also
als wir das erste mal ins stadion
zurückkehren konnten vor wenigen monaten
war das ein besonderes gefühl endlich
wieder die freunde zu treffen atalanta
zu sehen
jedes spiel von berger muss jetzt so als
sei es das letzte weil wir nie wissen
was noch passieren kann wir haben es am
eigenen leib erfahren
es war auch die liebe zum fussball die
bergamo am anfang der pandemie in die
krise stürzte
als atalanta bergamo im februar in der
champions league gegen valencia spielt
vor allem beim public viewing massen zu
schauen das corona virus schon unter
ihnen die euphorie beim 4 1-sieg
ansteckend tausendfach
nirgendwo sonst in italien sterben so
viele menschen wie in bergamo armee
laster bringen die särge in andere
gegenden weil in bergamo die kapazitäten
erschöpft sind bilder traumatisch für
ganz italien
särge damals mangelware der
bestattungsunternehmer giuseppe war was
sony hat damals sein gesamtes sortiment
nutzen müssen preisklasse ausstattung
wie sonst im todesfall es spielte alles
keine rolle
es gab keine nicht jeder sack war gut
genug sogar die aus pappe wir mussten
weiter fahren die leichen transportieren
viele todesfälle zu dieser zeit wird er
selbst krank und kommt nach deutschland
liegt einen monat auf einer
intensivstation in köln als ich
aufwachte war ich sehr verwirrt und an
verschiedenen schläuchen einem katheter
ich verstand nicht wo ich war und ich
habe mich erschreckt ich hatte angst
diese angst die bilder von bergamo sie
haben italien zutiefst geprägt die
impfbereitschaft ist hoch 80 prozent
sind mindestens einmal geimpft die große
koalition unter premierminister draghi
verordnet strenge maßnahmen und hält
daran fest auch als eine lautstarke
minderheit mitte oktober gegen den
greenpeace protestiert der
ministerpräsident verschärft sogar die
regeln seit anfang der woche gilt
vielerorts jetzt zweig
die situation in italien ist unter
kontrolle
und wir befinden uns wahrscheinlich in
einer der besten situationen in europa
vor allem dank der impfkampagne
wir wollen diese normalität nicht aufs
spiel setzen
und in diesem sinne haben wir die
maßnahmen ergriffen
in bergamo am krankenhaus papa giovanni
ventil resino erlebt das defa nova juli
tatsächlich so etwas wie normalität
die situation sei stabil sagt der arzt
der in der krise einen hilferuf in die
welt gesendet hatte als die klinik fast
kollabierte wo damals ambulanzen
schlange standen lehrer nicht mehr 90
bis 95 corona patienten pro tag wie zu
beginn der pandemie
jetzt sind es ein oder zwei pro tag in
der notaufnahme diese veränderung mit
der eindruck ist also sehr deutlich und
ich denke es gibt nur einen grund
er verfolgt die angespannte situation in
deutschen krankenhäusern und weil er die
überforderung die verzweiflung kennt ist
er voller mitgefühl
ich glaube wenn man jetzt so hart
getroffen als land das am anfang nicht
so schwer betroffen war dann aber 20
monate lang belastet ist das ist noch
schlimmer als unsere erste welle
also meine gedanken sind bei den
deutschen freunden was immer ihr braucht
was ich oder wir tun können ist hier
die menschen in bergamo sind dankbar das
schlimmste überstanden zu haben wieder
gemeinsam zum fußballspiel zu gehen und
danach zum essen mit freunden
ich hoffe dass was passiert es kommt nie
wieder wenn sich wirklich alle impfen
lassen damit das hoffentlich nie mehr
passiert denn sonst wer bei uns ja
wieder alles dicht
was ist da schon ein bischen kontrolle
ob man geimpft oder genesen ist sagen
sie wenn sie dafür alle an einem tisch
sitzen können bei giuliana